well I think you always miss you youth I
mean in in a way you you want it back
and that's the time when I was young and
my friends were young and we thought we
knew the score and we in our way we were
very we were very snobbish in a sense we
really thought we had a lot of things
going that nobody in the history of the
world had ever had going before we took
ourselves you know we had a high opinion
of ourselves and we had enormous fun
with the music and with each other and
with the drugs you know not everybody
was lucky it was there were risks people
did not always survive some of those
some of those ecstasy's but you know I
can't wish myself back there I I
wouldn't wish myself back there
it's an impaired as I might wish for you
know the youth again but it's an
imperfect world and it's such a
trade-off what you what you have to to
pay you know to be young and crazy
you'll have to not know so much you have
to not understand so many risks you have
to be so much braver than you're going
to be later it you know you're always
you're always trading off you know one
thing against another I mean the drugs
the world around the drugs was strange
and and very frightening but there are
effects that I had from psychedelics at
times that I would never dismiss as
illusionary I mean there are things it
seems to me that I saw experienced out
there on that kind of psychedelic level
that I swear
truths about how things are but they
don't I can't defend them or even
examine them very rationally I think you
know I think you know any one one thing
you that you learn from from those drugs
I think you see or you acquire a deep
suspicion that what we see normally is
no more than what we need to see as
creatures so many feet off off the
ground and our perception is really
functional and there may be a whole lot
more out there then then we are normally
equipped to see
I might
speaking for myself I'm not sorry that I
ever had those experiences well actually
if it's probably not true because there
were times when I was so frightened out
of my wits that I I think I would have I
would have traded it all to be to be out
of there and I couldn't recommend it to
anybody because I've seen too many
people really swept away and endangered
by it it's you know it's it's something
that one can't recommend I mean it to
recommend it with one person is is to
really perhaps do that person a great
disservice it's it's it's just sort of
taking your head in your hands and it
may go well and it may not go well so
it's you know just suggest to anybody
that they try it I would have to I think
I feel I really knew them very well and
would and II feel comfortable about any
outcome and I don't think I could get
that comfortable guessing you know
guessing what would happen to anybody